from cuts to Broken Bones these actors
took the notion of Blood Sweat and Tears
a little too literally for their craft
Scarface changed alucino career in more
ways than one the role of Tony Montana
seemed to permanently alter his acting
moving forward and the film was a
surprise critical disaster after Pacino
had starred in pretty much nothing but
winners throughout the 70s the tide
eventually turned on Scarface and it was
re-evaluated as a classic but the
experience had already done permanent
damage to Pino both internally and
externally with his character frequently
snorting cocaine throughout the film
Pino ended up doing lasting harm to his
nasal passages he wasn't snorting real
cocaine on set of course but the powdery
stand in substance still did damage
since snorting large quantities of
pretty much any powder is harmful to one
degree or another this wasn't the only
injury he sustained or making Scarface
during the big final shootout Pacino
severely burned his hand on the barrel
of the prop gun he called his little
friend the Bur burm was so bad that his
hand became temporarily fused to the gun
and he was unable to work for weeks
afterward before shooting even started
Pino had already been injured in
pre-production kostar Michelle Fifer
went wild throwing and smashing dishes
as part of her audition which led to a
bloody gash on Pacino's
hand long before the animated Chris
prattled the Super Mario Brothers movie
took the world and the box office by
storm the first attempt to bring the
iconic video game character to the big
screen arrived all the way back in 1993
Super Mario Brothers starred Bob huskins
and John Leguizamo as the plum Duo
rather than taking a straightforward
approach to adapting the colorful
platformer the movie instead converted
the characters and setting into a gritty
dystopian action movie with little logic
consistency or care paid to the source
material with the bizarre adaptation
choices came a multitude of dangerous
stunts which led to huskins sustaining a
wild number of injuries Hoskins agreed
to do his own stunts early on much to
his detriment directors Annabelle jankle
and Rocky mton really put him through
the ringer during the chaotic shoot
huskins explained the scope of his
injuries to Entertainment Tonight I got
stabbed four times
electrocuted um broke a
finger um nearly got drowned the broken
finger was co-star on leguizamo's doing
while drunk con set leguisamo crushed
huskins finger with the sliding door of
a van how could that possibly happen
anything's possible Mario you just got a
leave lzo said he felt terrible for
huskins throughout the shoot every time
he had his stunt double take his place
while huskins stayed and got injured he
even considered faking his own injury
and solidarity with Hoskins but didn't
follow
through after starting out as a child
star shy lauff gained a reputation as a
method actor who frequently takes things
way too far in adulthood do it before
lauff got his entire chess tattooed for
real for David AES the tax collector he
had already gone even further for the
director's 2014 film fur Yuri for his
role as a World War II Tang Gunner lauff
took Extreme Measures to violently alter
his physical appearance in real life
rather than using makeup or special
effects the biggest alteration he
insisted on was having a tooth pulled
from his mouth after all of the dentists
he visited in La refused to yank a
healthy tooth he instead had the tooth
pulled by a random guy he met in a
parking lot just like the missing tooth
the wounds on his face in the film were
also 100% real labuff cut his face with
a knife right in front of co-star Logan
lurman and continuously reopen the
wounds throughout the shoot to create
real scars AA did not instruct Leff to
take these Extreme Measures but he was
appreciative of the lens lauff went to
for the film as said of lauff he is one
of the best actors I've worked with and
he's the most committed to Body and
Soul the modern era of the long running
Mission Impossible franchise has become
synonymous with star Tom Cruz pushing
himself to pull off the wildest stunts
possible Cruz has managed to execute all
of these huge stunts safely and in
spectacular fashion the one stuns that
significantly injured him in the series
was actually an extremely simple one by
his standards a leap from one rooftop to
another sandwich in the middle of an
extended chase scene in Mission
Impossible Fallout left Cruz with a
broken ankle that halted production what
are you waiting for I'm jumping out of
window the take that cause the injury
was used in the final edit of the film
and Cruz can even be seen limping away
as he finishes the shot in order to get
the film moving again as quickly as
possible Cruz put himself through weeks
of intense rehab to get back in fighting
shape director and co-writer Christopher
mcor ended up using Cruiser's recovery
time to make the finished film even
better he told Cinema Blend what the
ankle did was allow us to figure out the
holes in the script that we were still
struggling with and so we didn't rewrite
the script to accommodate the ankle but
we finished the script because the ankle
gave us the time Cruz's ankle injury
ended up being a blessing in disguise
and didn't slow down the actor's
ambition to keep pushing the envelope
with each installment of the
series Olivia Jackson is an actor
martial artist and stum performer whose
career sadly ended after an injury she
sustained on the set of Resident Evil
the final chapter in 2015 originally
brought on board for a fight scene
Jackson was also asked to serve a star
Mila yovich has stun double in a
high-speed motorcycle sequence according
to a lawsuit filed by the performer
director Paul WS Anderson personally
changed the conditions of the stunt
moments before shooting without
informing Jackson and as some reduce the
space between the motorcycle and the
camera which was mounted on a crane and
meant to raise over Jackson's head as
she rode straight at it the crane did
not move out of the way in time
resulting in a near fatal Collision that
left Jackson com for several days her
numerous injuries included several
lacerations a torn open cheek broken
ribs punctured lungs and partial
paralysis her left arm was also
amputated she has not worked on another
film since although the film's producers
initially promised to pay Jackson's
medical bills and cover her rehab cost
they needed and later blames the
incident on her in court after Jackson's
first lawsuit was dismissed in the US
she sued again in South Africa where the
film was shot and won on the second
attempt for 1995's Mortal Kombat Film It
was decided to have the actors do as
much of the action themselves as
possible only relying on stun doubles
when it was completely unavoidable this
led to many minor injuries amongst the
cast members some of fum had never
performed action before Robin Shu who
starred as Liu Kang had a background in
the Kong action film industry so he was
used to performing his own stunts and
fight scenes however even Shu was pushed
to the point of sustaining a
debilitating injury during the shoes
during his fight scene against reptile
Shu was launched through the air slammed
his back against a narrow pillar and
crashed to the ground even though Shu
nailed the stunt on the first take
Anderson made him do it over and over
again and only stopped when Shu
fractured a couple of ribs on the last
impact Shu recounted the injury to The
Hollywood Reporter saying I did it one
time and it was fantastic and Paul
Anderson said well can you do it again
because he's such a perfectionist so we
did it 10 times but what if all the
Legends were
true what Legends the original the Evil
Dead took a tiny budget and a boatload
of creativity and turned it into a
beloved horror franchise that remains
ongoing to this day the budgets for the
first two films in the series were so
dangerously small that many corners
needed to be cut in order to get the
project finished and out into the world
the shoot was rif with injuries both
small and large reportedly the Evil Dead
producer Rob Tupper even said something
along the lines of how he enjoys it when
an actor bleeds since it means he got
value for money the entire cast was
subjected to grueling conditions but no
more harmed more than star Bruce
Campbell partway through the shoot
Campbell broke his ankle in the middle
of a take and he got absolutely no
sympathy from the producer or writer
director Sam Ry Campbell told den of
geek we had to keep shooting the rest of
the night with salmon rub Tapper
cornering me in a room poking my ankle
with sticks because they thought it was
funny he's added that he's had to favor
that ankle ever since which always
reminds him of the shoot and of
Remy given that Apocalypse Now was one
of the only movie shoots played by
enough production troubles to Warrant an
entire documentary it should come as no
surprise that there were lasting
injuries on set multiple wounds were
incurred by the film star Martin Sheen
and one happened right in the opening
scene audiences are introduced to
Captain Willard while he is in the
middle of a drunken freakout in a hotel
room the scene was filmed on Sheen's
36th birthday while he was trash for
real and also working out some internal
issues every time I think I'm going to
wake up back in the jungle one of
Sheen's improvised impulses was to
demonstrate Willard's lethal
hand-to-hand combat skills by punching a
real mirror that happened to be in the
room which broke and cut open his hand
the blood in the scene was all real and
Sheen insisted to director Francis Ford
Copa that they keep shooting instead of
breaking to get him the necessary
medical treatment he still has the scar
in his hand to this day as serious as a
hand wound was it was eclipsed by
Sheen's near fatal heart attack that
arrived later on during
production best known these days for her
role on Stranger Things when owna Ryder
got a start in the 80s in films that
would go on to become Classics like
Heathers and Beetlejuice in 2002 Ryder
paired it with Adam Sandler for Mr Deeds
the movie stuck Rider with not just her
worst onset injury but also the worst
injury of her life she told w magaz
scene I never broke a bone into the
movie until I did Deeds while filming
the sequence where she and Sandler ride
bikes down the Central Park staircase
Ryder got a heel caught in the bike
pedal which led to a crash down the
steps she describes continuing to shoot
that night and not realizing how much
pain her arm was in until she woke up
the next morning she recalled well I'm
an actress I'm trained to hide my pain
but eventually I went to the doctor and
it was broken in three places she
considered it lucky that the brakes
happened on her joints which meant that
her arm wasn't placed in a cast and
filming could continue as normal without
needing to hide the injury on camera in
a terrible bit of bad luck Ryder re
broke the same arm later that year when
a news camera rammed into her as she was
swarmed by the Press on her way into a
courthouse for a hearing related to a
shoplifting
arrest years ago the sets of Hong Kong
martial arts movies were known as
dangerous places to work with the Stars
routinely doing their own stunts and
large portions of films even improvised
on the spot one such film was 1992's
once upon a time in China 2 in which
Donnie Yen played the film's main
villain opposite Jet Lee the big final
fight between Yen and Lee is a film's
highlight but came at the cost of Yen
sustaining a serious injury Yen told GQ
the way we worked in Hong Kong for many
many many years is that we changed the
choreography as we go along freestyle
basically it's like a rapping contest as
Yen and Lee changed up the fight
choreography they kept challenging each
other to be faster until Lee eventually
slipped up after doing dozens of takes
and whacked the y in the eyebrow with a
very real very heavy bamboo pole Yen was
millimeters away from being blinded but
got away with a scar when Yen and Lee
fought each other on screen again a
decade later in hero a similar slip up
happened Lee caught Yen on the opposite
side of the face with his pointy prop
sword nearly blinding him in his other
eye like the first injury this one
required half a dozen stitches he
whacked me on one side 10 years later he
whacked me on the other side back in the
early days of Cinema the stars of Silent
comedies were already pushing the
envelope in terms of the stun they
pulled off on camera Charlie Chaplain
and Buster Keaton are the two most
famous names of this type during that
era but Harold Lloyd comes in at a close
third he was most famous for his daring
Clock Tower stun from safety Last which
later inspired Jackie Chan's death
toying Clock Tower drop in Project day
as impressive as Lloyd's clar stunt
already is it becomes even more
astounding when you learn that he ped
off his feeds while wearing a prosthetic
after losing part of his hand the injury
actually occurred while Lloyd was
promoting his collection of Silent
comedy shorts back in 1919 for some
reason that has never been properly
explained a real bomb was present on set
and Lloyd played around with it during a
photo shoot under the assumption that it
was a prop he realized it was real
moments too late and lost part of his
right hand in the blast his face was
also damaged and he lost his ability to
see temporarily but his sight luckily
return Lloyd kept making movies for many
years while disguising his injury with
various gloves and Prosthetics which
undoubtedly made each of his stuns more
challenging as one of the world's top
art Stars Michelle yo has sustained a
multitude of injuries throughout her
prolific career she had already been the
star of over a dozen Hong Kong action
films by the time she appeared in 1996's
the stuntwoman and incurred the worst
injury of her career yo described the
unsafe conditions of the Hong Kong
action film industry to the independent
saying back then the fights were insane
no CGI it was dangerous and risky it's
not fun the stun woman lived up to its
title by showcasing yo pulling off
multiple death defying stunt but one
went wrong the Fateful stunt required yo
to LEAP from an overpass onto the top of
a truck as it drove far beneath her yo
nailed the first take but was required
to do it again from a different angle on
the second attempt yo fell face first
and landed with a headqu between the
mattresses that were meant to cushion
her fall causing the rest of her body to
flip over and hyperextend backwards the
fall saddled her with multiple broken
ribs and a fractured vertebrae in her
spine requiring her to be immobilized
and her back and neck brace for an
extended period of time
while hospitalized and unable to move
yon gave up her career in favor of a
safer life oddly enough it was Quinton
Tarantino of all people who visited yo
in the hospital and inspired her to keep
acting Taylor Hixon made International
headlines after filing a lawsuit against
the producers of the horror film
incident in a ghost land while filming a
shot that required her to press her face
against the glass window of a door while
pounding on it the glass broke and
sliced her face and neck Hixon told
deadline the craft service lady held my
faith together with napkins in her hands
she went through so many napkins there
was so much blood the injury required 70
stitches and multiple medical procedures
but she was left permanently disfigured
Hixon played a supporting role in the
film and the incident occurred on her
last day on set the film was directed by
Pascal losier best known for his work in
the new French extremity movement while
filming the shot losier kept telling
Hixon to hit the glass harder and harder
until it eventually shattered Hixon
actually stopped the shoot at one point
to ask the director and producers if it
was safe to keep hitting the door harder
and they assured her that it was the
winterpeg based production company
behind the film was fined
$40,000 after it pleaded guilty to
charges that it did not do everything
possible to guarantee hixon's
safety the sessions is based on the true
story of Marco Bryan a man who depends
on an iron lung to survive but wants to
lose his virginity via a sex surrogate
since John Hawks was playing a real
person he wanted his performance to be
as authentic as possible and that meant
embodying the role physically the real
Mark was unable to move from the neck
down and suffered from a severely
distorted spine to force a similar
result out of his own Anatomy Hawks took
to lying on top of a weirdly shaped
piece of foam what was at first mildly
uncomfortable began to do permanent
damage to Hawk's body after weeks of
production with them lying Motionless in
the contorted position for hours every
day Hogs took measures to try to
counteract the lasting effect such as
doing yoga on set but his doctor
eventually told him that his internal
organs have begun to migrate and that
the damage to his spine could likely
never be fully undone Hawks told vulture
my spine doesn't have enough movement in
One Direction and the opposite direction
has way too much
movement legendary martial artist Sam
hung has been injured countless times
throughout his lengthy tenure as a Hong
Kong action star while he was able to
power through the pain for the bulk of
his career hung's numerous injuries
eventually caught up to him as he aged
in 2017 he wound up being remanded into
a wheelchair by his doctor he would
remain wheelchair bound for the next 2
years until walking with the aid of
aaine in 2019 and finally being able to
walk on his own in time to receive a
Lifetime Achievement Award one of hung's
most physically demanding films was
ipman 2 which pushed him to his limits
as he neared his 60s in the middle of
the intense shoot hung required heart
surgery compounding his delicate stat
after the surgery hung was punched for
real in his fight scene against the
Twister which opened a gash on his face
that required four stitches proving his
metal hung spent an additional 5 hours
filming with the open gash in his face
before seeking medical treatment hung's
most prominent wound is the Deep curved
scar around his nose and upper lip that
can be seen in almost all of his films
however this had not happen on a film
set while defending a friend in abro
with real life gangsters hung was
stabbed in the face with a broken bottle
leaving him with a distinctive scar for
the rest of his
life after breaking through to
English-speaking audiences with his
villainous role in Casino Royale M
Michelson has spent the rest of his
career bouncing back and forth between
English and D is Productions one film
that bridged the gap between the two was
2014 a Salvation a Danish spin on the
American Western melson stars of the man
who gets caught up in a violent Revenge
plot after his wife and son are murdered
the injury melson sustained on set was
his own doing and didn't even occur for
the sake of a shot while falling around
on set with a heavy knife he bought
locally nson dropped it and nearly
sliced his finger clean off since he
couldn't wear a bandage on camera the
Deep womb was left open while they
continued shooting the film is set in
the American West but was filmed out on
the plains of South Africa and the
remote location made getting proper
medical treatment a bit of a challenge
shooting out doors in the dirt and dust
quickly led to mikkelson's wounds
getting infected local doctors were
ready to amputate his finger but
mikkelson convinced them to hold off
luckily after a couple of days of him
taking antibiotics the infection went
away leaving the actor with just a deep
gash to worry about your hands start
doing strange strange things John ree
Davies is best known for playing gim Lee
the dwarf in The Lord of the Rings
series one of his first roles after that
trilogy was the Hallmark TV movie leem
musketeer as the title implies the
project is a sequel to the classic The
Three Musketeers but instead of
following the original characters it
follows the next generation of
Musketeers Reese Davies plays poros one
of the original musketeers the actor was
injured during the shoot and ended up
suing the producers before the fem
musketeer was released while filming a
constructed set wall collapsed on top of
him which he blamed on the negligence of
the producers in the lawsuit he
described his injuries as severe and
permanent the project was filmed in
Croatia and Reese Davies was rushed to a
local emergency room where he was
treated for a fractured arm and a bloody
head
injury P laer has been in acclaimed
films like The Cider House Rules and
Enter the Void when nurse came along and
derailed her career while filming a
simple shot of her crossing the street
deera was struck by a stunt ambulance
and the driver turned sharply and
collided with her in the collision and a
subsequent fall to the street DEA West
her broke her tailbone and fractured her
spine the injuries required over 20
different surgeries and led to her
receiving
$73,000 in workers compensation not
ready to settle for just a 73k DEA wer
sued the production company liines gate
for the massive sum of $55 million the
lawsuit was partially about the major
injury she sustained but also about the
impact the whole ordeal had on her life
afterward she said that the film
completely destroyed her career and left
her with lasting physical and emotional
trauma she also took issue with the
filmmaker's decision to dub over her
voice with a different actor for
portions of the film without her consent
D La wer was unsuccessful in the lawsuit
and her case was eventually
dismissed HB hiiki wrote directed and
starred in the original Gone in 60
seconds but the film's messy plot is
just an excuse for a car chase that
lasts for over 40 straight minutes hicki
did all of the stunt driving himself
without acquiring permits shutting down
roads or even informing the public with
unsuspecting cards and pedestrian all
around and without much of a plan the
chase sequence was full of very real
danger and on the spot improvisation
ai's first major injury in the chase
scene came when he was rear ended on the
highway while going 90 mph by a random
car whose driver had no idea they were
part of a movie chase scene hii's car
was s spinning into a lampost injuring
him and almost totaling the car the
crash was incorporated into the story he
does hit a damn po his worst injury
arrived in the film's big climactic
stunt hiii jumped his car and 130 ft and
crashed it nose first straight into the
road with no padding or anything to
soften the blow he was left with a
compressed spine from the force of the
impact that permanently altered the way
he worked 15 years later licky died
while filming the sequel a scent
involving a collapsing water tower went
wrong when a support cable snapped and
knocked a telephone pole onto
[Music]
him